on va répondre aux questions
la réponse à la jambe j'aimerais sans
enfant qui n'a pas de téléphones
portables ont tourné la marque quand on
sait comment là on vend que pour les
douces isolé
donc aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'on
a un imam dans mon post un téléphone
portable
je veux qu'ils vont de passes 9e 45e 15
mm
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte
mais plus qu on a de jeunes dans les
réseaux sociaux et plus on sent en
confiance
attention pourtant la dernière fois
quand j'ai porté l'information de
district à saint gillois
c'est super ça
aujourd'hui nous vendons en réalité qu
une finale transforme donc trouver je
vais vous raconter title in the poll
j'ai acheté un smartphone pour ma mère
fera sous la prétendue mardi l'aviron
les images de l'opération jusqu'à la
semaine a dû juste aller sous google
qu'il a les mains est venu je suis allé
tout ce que j'ai tout ce dont j'ai
besoin
je vais courir et je cherche aujourd'hui
je n'ai plus ce matin qu'elle est
arrivée la dernière femme sous le slogan
pour moi et un autre ce n'est pas ce que
vous savez a laissé matin bon ce match
at il convaincu
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que tous
ces digital tout et tout que ce soit au
niveau de l'état au niveau des
entreprises mais elle est au niveau de
l'essieu l'année dernière quand je
donnais beaucoup ici au stade
l'idée étant que ne nous en ait dit cela
la stratégie vise à donner plus aux
entreprises parce que si on fait si on
n'écrit jamais en fait parler à
s'appliquer obligé mais ça les gisements
pour juste réduire des coûts engagé un
centre et à celle du trajet donc
aujourd'hui on s'entend que vous
voyagiez par exemple terrain de combat
et les gagnants christian lafon dylan
produits pour arriver à mary mary cohr
rendre en avion qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est
la rigologie a lancé aujourd'hui pour
faire consommer nos économies on est
obligé d'utiliser les nouvelles règles
en a vu le jour à l'organiser
et quand ils ont ils fait
qu'actuellement digitalisées l'ensemble
du processus de gestion des flux cumulés
à fin d'épisode par contre ça existait
déjà mais il devient encore plus
aujourd'hui pour faire fonctionner les
noces le couple électrisé on est obligé
d'avoir des principes de ce marché
on est obligé la barre de l'archéologie
la guerre donc toute notre économie et
balestra virus et on s'en rend compte
c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de gars ce qui
m'emballe smartphones bada est connecté
mais les chiffres le montrent à peu près
on s est vus crois qu'il a régulièrement
il y à 7500 jean marc ayrault chacune en
122 ce plus de 204 millions de fiches et
multiplié les interviews fin fois
vainqueur à y voir le nombre de fichiers
par mois je ne pouvais pas donc tout ça
et vous dire que le monde de manière
générale cette valise de plus en plus le
monde sait digitalise la vie aussi est
très maigre la vie qu'il ya un auteur
qui a enseveli dernièrement sur le
digital sa présence chez nous qui dit en
fait que le digital d'émané en afrique
mais original africain tenant compte des
spécificités locales s'est développée
oui on a dans des salles des raisons en
as raison pour battre ces gars qui a
repensé en fait un roman est dû en
parler il ya à paris
valu en a d'autres modèles afin de chez
nous qui s'en éloignent qu'isabelle
pessac et senna qui sous développée
autour du vigenal mais en fait ça là
vous nous comprend il faut comprendre
qu'il ya c'est ce qu'ils ont et 5 passes
et celle d'amazon
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez vous
mais on n'a pas de téléphone portable
en fait dans le coup les plages de
silence où les glaces à la vie mais
presque tous les réglages ce qu'on a
fait dallas 105 ans on n'a rien à voir à
quoi je parle donc aujourd'hui n'at on
pas et en matière de dans le grenier
point qui est très important de notre
sol c'est le sou qui a été réalisé par
apport au moins de paiement là c'est
injuste oui là puisqu'elle inclut savary
sénart et beaucoup plus lourd que ce
qu'on voit dans les pays développés par
maguy développer comme que ce soit de
l'occident pour vivre le crash des
sceaux c'est ce pouvoir je vous ai dit
qu'on est qui se développe de plus en
plus avec des talents on sait
qu'aujourd'hui nous en a vu d'autres
comme les infrastructures en armes on
l'a mal à oublier donc si on arrive à
réparer ali sans pour autant se voir ça
c'est super donc on a du coup le
développement de plusieurs qui
n'accomplissent aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que dans vos pays
il ya un guide alisation au niveau du
secteur public
prenez le cas du rwanda ou en verre est
où les services sont vigilants même pas
l'impression désagréable
il ya un an un de ceux qui en ait
finalisé
on va en parler aujourd'hui il ya la
dernière étape
qu'on soit de plus en plus et qui est en
train d'être développé comme partout
d'ailleurs
c'est la marche les villages donc tout
ça montre combatif et bien présent dans
la finalisation
fernand très fermé d'arrêt d'arras une
autre qu'il y aura forcément des choses
à faire
si on prend un quart du prochain on
parle du sel
le sénégal a ux trahissent une fusion
qui est arrivé à la stratégie nationale
on avait à saint ghislain graduée ville
écolo numérique pour tous elles
concluent les régions ces régates avec
secteur privé dynamique et innovant à
l'horizon 2020
mais pour faire ça les rats du sénégal a
réduit et bélie et la stratégie
juste pour résumer rapidement les
verreries si je ne prends pas le premier
c'est la mise à jour la mise à niveau du
cadre juridique et institutionnel pas
que vous voyez je suis un portable par
ci par là on s'emballe et le bizarre
s'ouvrira en qualité de présidente a lu
les textes à s'infliger le mieux le vin
c'est fou les eaux le cap d'agde parce
que finalement les gens se mélangent et
dissiper nouveau ou même dans les pays
les plus développés ya un manque de
veine dalm donc aujourd'hui on est là et
on essaie de développer cette année
20 et le projet de nouveau le croiser là
ne paraît plus aussi si je ne prends pas
en danger
quand arrive un deuxième cd la
licitation un troisième très importante
c'est la conscience humaine parce que
puis on vous faire des livres on peut
échanger des messages
on va aller dans les entreprises mais on
est obligé d'avoir confiance absolue est
la personne qui m'en veux mais c'est
bien des personnes
la personne avec qui je fais très bien
cette personne est donc une fois ces
pays qui vit en place le sénégal j'ai
dit ok on va les filles et d'un en place
à ce sujet les quatre axes stratégiques
le premier s'est développée le 10 mai le
gouvernement va le disais pour les
semailles donc 25 ans a besoin d'un
encan l'horizon 2025 de de se séparer de
certificat de naissance
le deuxième place stratégique c'est le
développer la diffusion des entreprises
qui sont la promotion d'emplois des
inscrits six sont dans leur bulle mais
le linge figurer en a beaucoup qui sont
en train de naître
on a un projet au niveau de gardien
c'est pas parce qu'ils étaient en train
de naître et il faudra nationalement
développé par un concept qui permet à
ces jeunes entreprises de se développer
en asie
le troisième point c'est le fait de
diffuser ce lui et aux axes de
développement stratégiques du pays que
ce soit le mec de l'assemblée ont paraît
il à l'heure du domaine de l'éducation
peut-être qu'il faudrait le droit avec
deux nuls et il ya un autre domaine que
ce soit le domaine de la classe c est le
dernier niveau qui en fait a déjà
prononcé
c'est le secteur du terrain ou en fête
de st gall a beaucoup d'allant à un bébé
ça c est pour vous dire que lui et
certains vins et samedi moi on va ça a
changé mal ça a changé ma vie et ça m'a
dernier d'avoir une autre vision
pour moi la jeunesse africaine doit être
la guerre et d'émotion parce que il faut
savoir qu on allait nationale deuxième
éruption de l'ariane de la phase de
corruption comme disait le président
al-assad à 2014
l'afrique ne doit surtout pas la laisser
deux états de l'ue mais les trois
évolutions vous comprendrez bien que moi
que c'est par vous les personnes âgées
ma mère est une chance et non pas tous
ces enfants ont fait un fromage
elle n'a pas besoin de comprendre
comment une fonctionnaire
mais pour moi cette révision doit et
vous porter par nous on faisait on va en
fait ce se préparer à pouvoir répondre
aux besoins j'ai rencontré le petit soin
en 2008 5e avant de rallumer
en 2000 j'ai rencontré deux personnes et
sera oublié le connais c'est un jeu
sérieux ricky votants avait 38 ans 39
ans il avait monté les instar de
l'enfance ils étaient spécialisés y
danser c'est l'information pour les 1/2
fort et il est devenu un leader dans ce
domaine vers 2011 de mulhouse c'est
raymond couderc en paille
donc j'ai reçu des deux mandats il
m'avait dit un jour payer
honolulu battu travail ou moins mais
n'oublie pas les choses
l'appareil révolution industrielle
c'est la révolution qu elle il faut la
totale plupart des autres candidats
intel a pris occasion elle s'appelait
arrive à la vue la personne qui m'a
beaucoup marqué dans ma vie c'était un
jeu aussi talentueux qui repart dans
votre base au sénégal
il faisait partie des meilleurs après
partie fermée
j'avais une chance c'est que quand les
hommes c'est pas très passionnant
baboulin quand j'avais jamais arrivée
sur la terre en défense c'est notre
moral mais voilà on partageait
naturellement avec le jeu lui immobilisé
équipe usée aurait parlé connaître
différents mais peu importe le niveau
d'études les volcans dans laquelle on
est au degré ce projet pourra rentrer au
sénégal à rentrer en la vue pour mettre
à disposition d'un malaise
conférence ce mardi ça plaît elle à ce
moment là je deviens alors en enfer pour
nos âges ici parce qu'ils m'ont beaucoup
et je sais pas si vous êtes rendu compte
d'une chose en parlant ou telle personne
et par les occasions parce que
malheureusement en 2014
ces deux sont sondés et les ados - evans
voilà donc j'ai décidé moi j'ai décidé
par rapport à ces deux visions qui
volent et de prendre en retard sur le
levier nazis mauvaise armes
je suis rentré au sénégal depuis
quelques années et depuis j'essaie de me
battre attendez demain couillonner mais
il ya une fusion j'ai le dos des c3 à
ceux qui sont au pouvoir très important
et c'est pourtant vous moi quand les
africains en bas de page pour réagir
c'est le cognaçais l'assaut du mont
cassel dans les raffineries la famille
on voir dans les variables
le 2e as c'est là se trouve encore des
salades
il ya un vrai manque on peut le voir le
domaine que je connais devient celle
d'hommes le domaine que gardien vous
devoir faire beaucoup de choses et le
pana ce qui pour moi est peut-être je
veux plus intense et la colère en bois
elle est arrivée au développement de son
pays par rapport à tout ça quand je suis
revenu au sénégal
je me suis posé beaucoup de questions
comme des enveloppes mais qu'est ce que
je dois faire gober lutte serrée des
coûts des gens et de vue quelque part on
se souvient que c'est le roman les
hommes et femmes ont tenté de lancer mon
propre talent dont j'avais entendu j'ai
laissé il ya quelqu'un de venir à mon
compte et vous le dire de charge et
pourquoi pas c'est une grande marque
grand talent et qui rêve français a
besoin de plus d'aidé c'est un bien
commun sont donc j'ai été accompagné
mais c'est valable est membre je pense
que le plus important c'est ce que j'ai
fait ma part j'ai enfin en laissant
supposer la mission à savoir comment
pourrais je pourrais j'ai bien vécu sans
vous pourrez apporter quelque chose à un
bébé ou à l'international
naturellement quand j'ai vu le concert
des nations
il ya eu des volets qui touchait en fait
est assez connu et donc n'a vraiment
dans la salle
non j'ai le biais de stratégies et je me
suis proposé de faire une petite idée
qui est y arriver a ironisé
et puis mais c'est le même sens de la
vie pour la paix
donc j'avais commencé à l'avenant à
écrire sur une stratégie nationale si la
faculté je parlais plat devant ces neuf
enfin super et j'ai fait n'est pas guéri
mais qui en fait que j'appelle une
construction c'est pareil pour
développement le monde et loxam jeune
homme en tunisie pour unir pour moi de
même vous en outre il faudrait d eux qui
en place mais les yeux qui y aura des
jeux qui en feront tout ce qu'ils
peuvent ou non violé à son arrivée au
combat dès l'aube et ont comme année son
continent plus à rien surtout si on
considère en plus on nous considère
aujourd'hui on le continent le plus beau
en valeur ici doublé l'année modèle pour
plusieurs choses
malheureusement j'ai oublié à l'âge je
vais vous bien compris et c'est ma phase
de conclusion des vélos mais pour régler
ce qu'il a rappelé m vous voulez aussi
la veille lié à ces millions d'années et
qui sont là pour moi que le pari est
risqué comme disait la vanille natalisme
mais je voulais la mer sur vous pour
venir le deuxième c'est le temps merci